I hear that you were roommates with
Eddie Raymond Jamie Doran Andrew
Garfield and Charlie Cox who was the who
was the coolest in your gang I don't
think any of us were cool we were the
kind of guys that would go to The
Standard Hotel to play pingpong and
order one cocktail between us because we
couldn't afford anymore and so all these
kind of out of work English actors go
over to LA to try and get work which we
tend not to get but what we would do is
call home and tell our families that we
were working incredibly hard it was a
lot of um going up for the same
auditions prepping each other try to get
the same work a lot of guys who ended up
doing pretty
well the Oscar goes to Eddie Redmond
deadevil this claric book character
that's got so steep in history vampire
they were all roommates and I was like
always invited as an afterthought
there'd be like one slice of pizza left
and i' be like is it really for me